- So the district attorney, Bruce Castor,
decided to issue a promise to Cosby
that they weren't going to go
forward with prosecuting him,
and there is some controversy here
as to whether there is
an agreement or not.
Cosby waived his Fifth Amendment rights
against self-incrimination
and gave four depositions
in the civil case
that Constand brought against him.
The idea is that if the prosecutors
weren't gonna be able to
criminally prosecute Cosby,
at least the victim could
recover civil damages,
which she was able to do.
She won millions of dollars.
And even in the civil case,
Cosby could've exercised
his Fifth Amendment right
not to incriminate himself
but he decided to give the depositions.
The depositions included
all kinds of inculpatory statements,
including the fact that he gave Quaaludes
to women and then had sex with them.
But that's only half the story.